[Music]
you
hello oh how are you actually my mom was
saying you should come over next time
and for a bid that I think it'd be
really fun
yes the tree must meet you this time
mm-hmm you okay yeah I'm just tired okay
um remember I said we were going to get
the ferry over but we went over all the
days yeah I think I'm gonna have enough
actually why don't we do the sausage
yeah yeah yeah okay
hey a cinema no I'm just tired okay yeah
all right yeah yeah sure if you have a
sleep under
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wrong let's put my card for daddy no I
told you before you've already put it on
top of the TV they're going round
another the day what do you think
already good what we could stop the
world
okay you must have got the wrong train
into Charing Cross and this one at 45
past I guess if you left your antacid
three you would have been here by my
wires Johanna have such weird earrings
has she's not worried about them license
daddy once all is so far from us oh
we've talked about this time please
don't start again here give me your
plate you must be starving don't start
anything before he comes
Rion Rion Rion Rion contact me and
please don't speak to me like that lion
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Applause]
and shortly after that dad Anais Joanna
mr. America so I'm sorry you answer that
but I can totally see why you're not so
keen about people leaving trying to make
you look welcome home sign I think I
could probably do with that one maybe so
do you want to see my photographs
oh hello this idea right how about you
go and run yourself a nice warm bar and
in the meantime I'll cook us some red
delicious foods and welcome home dinner
and then officers we can look at the
photos together on sofa sounds perfect
can we have cheesecake okay
[Music]
thank you for watching liking and
subscribing if you want more why not
visit us in person and attend a class or
take a look at our shop at the link on
your screen now